Oh
[Music]
what's up guys so to become an Avenger
other like trials or an idiot do me a
favor can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man just stay close
to the ground you shoulda spider-man
from YouTube
can you swim in them on the exploiters
Oh dad no you know I have to still a
shield temperature this alone the rich
and the powerful like start they don't
care about the world's changing boys and
we changed to weapons a crazy dangerous
mission Vader forget the flying monster
guy there are people who handle the
story you read the weapons Barry with a
230 you missed it
[Music]
what if somebody died I was just trying
to be like you I want you to get better
I'm gonna need the check back well
nothing without this suit if you're
nothing without this suit then you
shouldn't have it I screwed up you need
to stop carrying the weight of the world
on your shoulders I want you to
understand I'll do anything to protect
my family
I know you know what I'm talking about
don't mess with
I'll kill you and everybody you grow up
here
a guy is still out there I've just got
to do this on my life
just don't do anything stupid all right
yeah hey guys what's up happy spider-man
day if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything there's a
special action figure giveaway going on
I'll explain at the end of the video but
this trailer really just hives up more
of the vultures character and he has
this really interesting symmetry with
spider-man because in a way they're both
dumpster divers remember way back during
civil war where Tony Stark was picking
through his room going Oh where'd you
get all this crap Oh your dumpster diver
this is great
picking through other people's castoffs
to make your own technology this really
smart kid with aspirations of greatness
showing a lot of initiative so the way
they're talking about spider-man is that
he's this little kid looking up at the
Avengers so it's sort of like the kids
view of an Avengers world with Tony
Stark up at the top and it's the same
thing for Michael Keaton's vulture
character he's sort of like a normal guy
looking up from a villains perspective
so the really cool thing here if you're
a longtime comic book fan this is a deep
cut there's a group called damage
control it's the name of a comic book of
a group of people that are assigned to
clean up messes after big superhero
battles so what happens is is that this
version of the vulture owns damage
control so after the Chitauri invasion
like after these big battles after stuff
like sokovia they come in and clean up
so that's how he earns his living he's
sort of like a dumpster diver and picks
through things gives them to the
tinkerer and they create new inventions
but Tony Stark comes along and he starts
cleaning up the messes remember the big
Hulk battle during Johannesburg that
wanted urban destruction people always
make fun of that in movies now well
Robert Downey jr. said he felt like Tony
Stark went in and cleaned that up like
he paid to clean that up so what's
happened is is that stark tech has
stolen a lot of the work that Michael
Keaton's vulture character would get so
his livelihood is God and he blames Tony
Stark for that so that's where he
revolts puts his team together and
that's where you get to the Tinker
helping him build the [ __ ] our base
flight suit with the Shocker and Donald
Glover's character working together
two really cool Easter Egg about damage
control yes it was a comic book but
spider-man was in that early issue it
was a company that was co-founded by
Tony Stark and Wilson Fisk the kingpin
you know kingpin big spider-man villain
the powers that be haven't said anything
about putting him in any of the MCU
movies kingpin is just a really big
character he has to make it in at some
point in Vincent D'Onofrio it's like
make it happen I want to be in a
spider-man movie we'll see if they can
make our dreams come true because most
of the MCU actors have said yeah we're
not going to crossover with the TV shows
it's just a completely different
universe even though they build it as
everything is connected so really when
it comes to stuff like that it's not
over till it's over it's a case-by-case
basis I think the kingpin there's a
strong chance that he'll make it into
the movies there is a little bit of
Captain America in here a lot of people
are wondering if they shot new footage
for this like I said it'd be really
stupid for him to be hanging out in New
York City as a wanted fugitive I think
it's more likely he'll have a bigger
role in the Black Panther movie because
Bucky is still chilling on ice but
there's all kinds of roundabout ways
that they can include Captain America
and it's like him watching footage of
him stuff that they didn't shoot for
other movies but they sort of inserted
for this but really this is more of an
Iron Man centric movie and we got
confirmed new Iron Man redesigned suit I
know everybody was wondering when the
toy came out they're like that's not new
turns out it is it's actually colored to
look like the ultimate spider-man
costume so it might be a big upgrade it
might just be a slight redesign
hopefully we'll find out in the movie
because he's getting a whole bunch of
new toys new suits that is during
infinity war you see him fly in here
during this big fairy save so they
really left off a bunch of this scene
like spider-man has taken all these
villains down then Iron Man flying in to
help them out so there are a lot of
moments in the trailer where you see
confrontations with spider-man in the
vulture any sort of talks to him giving
him lines that you may have heard or may
sound similar to stuff from earlier
movies what are you without that suit
big man in a suit of armor
take that off what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist
so spider-man now has to come up with
the answer to that question if you're
nobody without that suit then you don't
deserve it
I love the joke about him letting Ned
Leeds put it on can I put the mask on
you get a better look at how it actually
comes on and off like it's sort of
form-fitting he runs into the alleyway
like you would see in a typical
spider-man comic or in the previous
movies so I love Iron Man's quote like
he's trying to get him to be a quote
unquote
friendly neighborhood spider-man don't
worry about the big Avengers problems in
saving the world you're not ready yet
so you have to imagine a little bit of
Fast Times Ridgemont High Spicoli stuff
going on here where he basically has to
get his [ __ ] together and learn to be a
real hero and that's when he'll become
an Avenger like he's kind of already an
Avenger right now it's more of this
internal journey for him the great power
great responsibility thing without
actually overtly saying that in the
Uncle Ben way and I'm really to see how
they addressed that in this movie but as
lazy as Tony Stark seems he really is
trying to teach him a lesson and like
spider-man needs to believe in himself
to craft his own identity and that's
when he'll be ready to join the Avengers
in the next big movie which is like what
are the next big appearance is going to
be but in that way you can see how
they're spending a lot of this movie
helping define who spider-man is so that
when he's in the big movie with like 60
plus characters you'll know exactly
what's going on you'll be able to say
this is what spider-man would do in this
situation because you know the character
because they spent all this time setting
that up that's really what this movie is
all about like if you're nobody without
the suit so who is he without the suit
he still has to be spider-man without
the special shiny stark tech suit so
Tony Stark takes the suit back maybe he
gets it back by the end of the movie
definitely by Avengers infinity war this
is Michelle's character I know there's a
lot of questions about who she is but it
just has more context to this Washington
Monument scene where lizallen the rest
of friends are stuck up in there so it
seems like all this happens before the
big Barry's safe that's the moment
before the big climax of the film where
he battles the vulture using the old
costume and then sort of like proves
himself proves his worth is a reward for
that presumably gets the suit back but
you can kind of see how there's pair
between the two of them they're both
very working-class kind of people the
vulture still very evil I mean he's
insane up in the head that's why he's a
comic book villain but I love the way
they end the trailer
don't do anything stupid okay and then
you see that they play and save but
there's a really important line that
happens you know it sounds like before
he goes to face the vulture without the
stark tech suit where he says I just got
to do this on my own but you feel like I
feel like the big twist here is that he
does need his friends because a big
thing in the comics is that spider-man
is not a solo act it's a spider family
like even if he doesn't actually have
Mary Jane like he's not married her he
doesn't have a kid his friends are still
a very important part of his life like
the whole idea is that nobody can put
the weight of the world on their
shoulders just like Aunt May says you
can't do this by yourself
so maybe somehow even though they're not
superheroes they'll be able to help them
out in some way the other big thing
sidenote sony went crazy at CinemaCon
this weekend so of course everybody was
asking about the new venom spin-off
movie the silver sable movie which is
something that sounds even weirder but
Tom Holland said that he was open to
being in those but he hasn't seen any
scripts and that would be how he would
decide so he's going to look at the
scripts for those movies when they're
ready and will decide whether or not
he's going to be in them so that answers
your question about spider-man
in an r-rated venom movie so I think
Sony is going to do everything it can to
get a script that Tom Holland likes so
that he'll participate and they don't
have to have some crazy workaround
because there's no way that you can do
venom without spider-man you don't need
a lot of spider-man but you do have to
have them in there so I'll do more venom
videos when we find out more about that
but they have seemingly confirmed that
it's supposed to be their entry into
rated-r superhero films I already did a
video talking a little bit about that so
I had a link at the end of this let me
know in the comments what do you think
about this trailer I love it tells a
little bit more of the story of the film
you find out more about the characters
it's not just all the flashy stuff but I
am giving away those spider-man action
figures all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video I'll do more spider-man homecoming
later this week I'll announce the winner
when I post that video leave all your
requests for spider-man videos in the
comments below what's going to happen
later today is we got some new flash so
I'll post that I got a whole bunch
Marvel whole bunch of DC coming this
week it's going to be great while you
wait for that you can click here for all
the Justice League trailers that I
posted and you can click here to learn
all about that Xena
Sonne movie thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you in the next video